les avalanches sont encore tuées dans
les alpes
l'imprudence des skieurs est cette fois
en prose françois ceyrac attaque
vivement le programme commun le patronat
de replacer le débat électoral sur le
plan économique le tiercé pour gagner il
fallait jouer aujourd'hui le 12 le 4 le
invité du journal jean rochefort césar
du meilleur acteur de l'année
bonsoir mais avant de développer tous
ces titres je dois vous signaler que
dans la deuxième partie de ce journal
vers 20h15
nous vous présenterons un reportage un
peu exceptionnel réalisé par jacques
séguin et jean-louis saporito
conséquence de l'énorme succès du livre
et du feuilleton télévisé que vous
pouvez voir d'ailleurs chaque semaine
sur antenne 2 route racines les noirs
américains retourne en afrique à la
recherche de leurs origines et nos
correspondants aux états unis en fête
avec eux ce retour aux sources un
document tout à fait étonnant premier
titre donc
le mauvais temps et les avalanches en
montagne pratiquement incroyable malgré
les conseils de prudence répété à
longueur de journée par les responsables
de la sécurité dans les stations de
sports d'hiver et les villages des alpes
des skieurs inconscients sont allés
faire du hors piste à chamonix sur les
pentes de l'aiguillé du midi
résultat tous les chamoniards l'avait
prédit avalanche
bilan un mort et trois blessés de
nationalité suisse
voilà donc qui allonge la liste déjà
bien longue des victimes de la neige de
ces derniers jours toutes les radios les
journaux les chaînes de télévision
annonçait hier que ces avalanches avait
tué 15 personnes vendredi et samedi
dernier dans les alpes du nord
aujourd'hui malgré la diffusion de ces
informations
une autre coulée de neige a emporté six
hommes qui pratiquait le ski sauvage à
l'aiguillé du midi
alors comme d'habitude les sauveteurs
sont repartis ils ont dégagé un corps
cet après midi à retrouver cinq
survivants tout le monde pourtant savez
à chamonix
l'école de ski le bureau des guides des
skieurs et la gendarmerie que de
nouvelles avalanches pouvaient partir à
tout moment dans la vallée où l'on
dénombre sens couloirs avalancheux ce
dont 30 % seulement ont été vidangé la
préfecture de haute-savoie avait
déconseillé la pratique du ski pendant
le week-end
certaines remontées mécaniques étaient
fermés mais voilà le ski la neige c'est
un peu comme le soleil et l'autoroute on
pense toujours que l'accident la vie
vrac aux autres il est arrivé
aujourd'hui comme hier bêtement en
débarquant d'un téléphérique des
victimes de nationalité suisse à
chamonix
les français sont relativement docile il
observe les conseils de prudence les
étrangers américains japonais viennent
en france pour faire du ski avalanche
connais pas ce n'est pas leur problème
non seulement au ski mais en plus en
dehors des pistes et c'est là l'une des
principales la prudence la mort blanche
elle ne fait pas de distinction et l'a
frappé elle frappera encore on
apprivoise pas la montagne
il est vieux chat moignard les dents de
la neige son redoutable elles mordent
et pourtant l'information circule dans
les stations on ne ferme pas les yeux
quand l'or blanc se fâche là il faut
être extrêmement prudent il faut pas
sortir des pistes qui ont été dame et
qui ne présentent aucun danger quand les
conditions sont bonnes on l' annonce
toujours dans la station que les pistes
que nuon fils est sans danger
mais quand on n'a pas annoncé cette
information aussi longtemps les gens ne
devraient pas sortir des pistes
la montagne a été aménagé dans de
nombreuses stations pour bloquer la
neige des cartes d'avalanche existe dans
les mairies elle couvre les 70
principales stations de ski françaises
et donne toutes les précisions relatives
à la position des coulées de neige leur
déclenchement habituel leur trajet leur
fréquence mais ces cartes et c'est bien
dommage sont confidentielles elles ne
peuvent être consultés par le public
alors il faut s'informer comme avant de
prendre la route pour ne pas se faire
piéger la montagne présente des dangers
son manteau neigeux est instable en
période de redoux comme c'est le cas en
ce moment et l'avalanche est au détour
du chemin durant l'hiver 75 76 qui fut
une rude saison 50 à la lanchon emporté
en france 191 personnes 60 ont été
ensevelis quarante-et-une tuées et 42
blessées
la saison 77 78 sera moins meurtrières
si les conseils de prudence ont observé
la neige est attirante mais la montagne
dangereux voyons maintenant les
prévisions météo pour demain lundi elles
ne sont pas très rassurantes pour la
montagne
il va encore neiger sur les alpes le
jura et le nord-est de la france
il y aura de la pluie ailleurs et des
gelées dans la matinée l'après-midi le
temps hésitera entre des averses de
pluie ou de neige des ardennes aux alpes
du nord et des éclaircies demain soir de
toute façon il pleuvra après des fautes
de la manche à chaque week-end ou
presque que la parution des
hebdomadaires et la publication de
sondages quelques surprises dans celui
révélé par le point
à propos du vote des couples exemple en
politique
le mari et la femme ne se disent pas
tout il ya seulement 64% des hommes et
66% des femmes qui connaissent le vote
de leurs conjoints l'isoloir n'existe
pas que le jour du scrutin donc
autre chiffre intéressant dans 46 % des
couples mari et femme ne vote pas de la
même manière
c'est au parti socialiste et au rpr
qu'ils sont les plus unis l'infidélité
politique est la plus grande au parti
républicain autre sondage celui publié
par le matin
demain d'après une étude de l'institut
louis harris france le quotidien affirme
le parti communiste ne peut plus
objectivement se prévaloir du titre de
partie de la classe ouvrière 33 % des
électeurs ouvriers
ont l'intention de voter socialiste 35 %
ont l'intention de voter commune pas de
sondages dans l'express mais une
interview de jean jacques servan
shreiber
notre objectif dit le président du parti
radical est d'aboutir à un groupe
parlementaire pour l'udf l'union pour la
démocratie française dans la prochaine
assemblée
il faut donner à la réforme sa base
parlementaire
et puis dans l'actualité il faut savoir
également que l'on votait aujourd'hui à
issy les moulineaux élections
municipales partielles
le conseil d'état ayant invalidé les
derniers résultats qui caron ancien
champion de natation élu avec la liste
majoritaire n'habitait pas depuis
suffisamment longtemps à issy les
moulineaux
sans doute les résultats de cette
élection vers 23h35 dans le dernier
journal
vervecken à cinq semaines des élections
législatives
même ralenti pendant le week-end le
débat électoral continue les menaces
d'application du programme commun
explique l'actuel le spéculation sur le
franc dit le ministre de la culture
monsieur d'ornano si l'opposition
l'emporté l'action internationale de la
france serait paralysée même type
d'argument employés aujourd'hui par
monsieur françois ceyrac du cnpf le
patronat français
il crie lui aussi haro sur le programme
commun je lui reproche deux choses
d'abord de loi 1 située dans ce pays
directement ou indirectement un
gigantesque le système de
nationalisation soit par la
nationalisation direct de centaines et
de centaines d'entreprises soit par la
nationalisation indirecte à travers le
monopole du crédit et je lui reproche
une deuxième chose c'est que ce système
une fois installé nous mettra dans
l'incapacité d'affronter des concurrents
qui bénéficient de la liberté totale
pour leur stratégie leur politique
commerciale leur prix et nous serons je
le crains j'en suis sûr à bref délai
hors d'état de maintenir notre place
dans le monde où se rencontrent
un au repli sur l'hexagone ce faisant
vous exprimer une préférence et les
chefs d'entreprise que vous représentez
prennent parti dans la campagne
électorale où nous gardons bien de
prendre des positions le caractère
politique
quand même votre prise de position est
plutôt favorable à la majorité qu'à
l'opposition non lé fabre à la liberté
mais en intervenant aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous ne risquez pas de favoriser
cette réaction de panique et
d'encouragement particulier sur une
manoeuvre contre le franc par exemple je
pense que certains certaines inquiétudes
qui se sont manifestées au cours ces
derniers jours tienne effectivement à
l'idée que se font certains nombre de
français ou d'étrangers ou d'étrangers
de ce que peut-être la situation
économique sociale et politique de la
france dans l'hypothèse où le programme
commun serait appliquée mais en ce qui
nous concerne notre seule volonté c'est
d'éclairer les français sur la portée
réelle du programme commun réaction de
monsieur antoine pinay ancien ministre
des finances après la démission du pdg
de manufrance hier le drame c'est
l'ingérence de la politique d'où
qu'elles viennent at-il en substance a
déclaré monsieur pinet je me suis rendu
compte à propos de manufrance contre
monsieur boulin le ministre délégué aux
finances et son entourage on ne semblait
pas d'accord sur les moyens à employer
pour sauver manufrance à l'étranger de
cessez le feu dans l'actualité de ce
dimanche l'un proposé par le vietnam au
cambodge avec début de négociations
immédiates
pas de réponse de phnom penh pour
l'instant l'autre cessez-le-feu est
effectif au tchad depuis ce soir on l'a
appris il ya une heure en effet un
accord de paix vient d'être signé entre
le gouvernement tchadien et le chef
rebelle
hissène habré vous savez que pour nous
l'amitié entre le peuple acadien et le
peuple français
n'est pas vain mot hissène habré en 1975
au moment de la sphère clos sera alors
qu'ils réclamaient aide médicale et
matériel militaire en échange de son
otage
hissène habré aujourd'hui âgé de 35 ans
ancien licencié en droit ancien sous
préfet étaient entrés en révolte en 1971
à l'occasion d'une mission de
conciliation auprès du chef historique
de la rébellion tchadienne
abbassi dit qu entre les deux hommes les
relations vont peu à peu se dégrader en
1976 hissène habré perd son rôle de
leader depuis cette époque d'ailleurs la
rébellion tchadienne s'est divisée en
plusieurs fractions rivales on parle
maintenant de trois ou même cinq armées
qui ne comptent parfois que quelques
dizaines de combattants
l'accord de cessez-le-feu signé entre le
chef de l'état félix malloum et hisséne
habré prévoit notamment une amnistie
générale et la formation d'un
gouvernement d'unité nationale
cela dit la portée de cet accord risque
d'être limité car ils cénabre n était
plus qu à la tête d'environ 300 hommes
qui ont fait totalement sécession avec
le reste de la rébellion
d'autre part cet accord ne devrait avoir
aucune conséquence sur le sort des deux
otages récemment enlevé est actuellement
aux mains d'une borne qui n'a
semble-t-il aucun rapport avec la
rébellion organisé la rencontre jimmy
carter anouar el-sadate toujours aucune
précision sur ces entretiens tenus à
camp david dans la résidence
présidentielle américaine
loin des oreilles indiscrètes et des
journalistes hier cependant le président
égyptien a obtenu l'appui officiel d'une
puissance non négligeable puisqu'il
s'agit de la chine populaire en israël
aujourd'hui à l'issue du conseil des
ministres hebdomadaire le gouvernement
israélien a reconnu que les
conversations militaire du caire entre
l'egypte et israël ont enregistré un net
progrès pendant ce temps à alger les
chefs d'état arabes hostiles aux
initiatives du président sadate viennent
de mettre au point un plan et des
mesures pour contrecarrer l'action de
l'egypte il demande l'aide de l'union
soviétique promettent d'aider en finance
et en armement les palestiniens et en
appelle même aux nations unies pour
faire condamner le président sadate qui
d'après eux n'a aucun mandat pour
représenter le peuple palestine
quelques télégrammes rapide encore le
rappelle d'abord des principales
informations sportives de la journée le
suédois sten marque est devenu champion
du monde de slalom spécial à garmisch ce
matin l'allemagne fédérale
devenue une championne du monde en bal
en battant l'union soviétique cet
après-midi changements dans l'équipe de
france de rugby pour le prochain match
contre l'irlande le 18 février au parc
des princes bourdon est remplacé par
bilbao de saint-jean-de-luz et puis
enfin le tiercé qui s'est couru à
vincennes cet après midi est d'ailleurs
la preuve que cette course du tiercé
voici les résultats du tiercé 12,4 17
points qui rapporte donc pour 510 1905
francs et dans un ordre différent 789
francs cinquante âmes honneur maintenant
aux césars 78 ces récompenses décernées
par la profession cinématographique aux
meilleurs vous allez peut-être suivi sur
antenne 2 hier soir en direct la
proclamation de ces césars je vous
rappelle les principaux lauréats le film
providence d'alain resnais sept césars
jacques dufilho pour le meilleur second
rôle marie dubois pour le meilleur
second rôle féminin
simone signoret meilleure actrice 78 et
jean rochefort meilleur acteur césar 78
ans ou argent aux forces
d'après vous ce genre support à quoi
sert un césar se faire surtout en a
parlé du cinéma à permettre aux
téléspectateurs de voir la famille des
gens de cinéma réunis dans une salle de
faire parler de nos films et hier de
parler un petit peu aussi d'un problème
et de nos angoisses et puis ça m'a fait
moi très plaisir personnellement et je
suis gt sont si vous faites que les
professionnels du cinéma me donne ce
césar ça sert aussi à ça ça sert à plein
de choses je trouve cette initiative est
très heureuse et très très justifiée
alors hier soir c'était la fête vous
étiez heureux de recevoir cet oscar mais
vous avez quand même une petite phrase
amer lors la joue site approximativement
vous avez dit je suis content que cette
soirée soit retransmise en direct par
antenne 2 au moins un soir où il n'y
aura pas de film alors voulez vous
développer
tu peux est-ce que télévision est
vraiment l'ennemi déterminée du cinéma
je viens ici en tant que comédien le
cinéma c'est vrai et aussi en tant qu
ancien comédien de télévision parce que
j'en ai fait beaucoup il ya 20 ans au
moment du direct j'ai une petite
nostalgie c'est vrai je voudrais qu'il
passe je voudrais je parle pas seulement
mon nom mais au nom toute la profession
jean et qu'il passe moi le film à la
télévision pour que les gens reprennent
le goût d'aller dans les salles
d'échanger leurs émotions dans des
salles de rire et de s'émouvoir comme le
font d'ailleurs les jeunes
il faudrait que les jeunes préfèrent
aller dans les salles et voir les films
dans les salles sur de grands écrans
il faudrait que les gens moins jeunes
prennent
conscience de cela et envie de se
retrouver à l'entracte avec les eskimos
et puis aussi pour que la télévision en
même temps se remettent à exister
je parle de la télévision de fiction
bien sûr laquelle j'ai participé j'ai le
souvenir moi il ya 20 ans le cinéma les
salles de cinéma était inquiète le mardi
soir points et dramatique pas c'est
parce que avec shakespeare avec
beaumarchais avec barma stellio lorenzi
les gens restaient chez eux pour
participer à un spectacle à une émission
qui était en direct d'ailleurs à
l'époque et qui était fait dans
l'enthousiasmé dans la joie et dans le
plaisir il y avait là une une création
c'était une époque où tous les comédiens
participer vous par exemple il ya cinq
ans qu'on n'avait pas fait de télévision
à ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes trop cher
pour la télé non c'est pas ça le
problème c'est parce que je ne peux pas
travailler sans enthousiasme je ne peux
pas travailler sans cet artisanat qui me
stimule et me donne envie d'agir et me
donne davantage d'imagination je trouve
maintenant ceci n'engage que moi que
c'est enthousiasme que cette joie de
travailler a disparu à la télévision il
faut qu'elle revienne il faut que la
télévision réexister il ne faut plus qu
elle soit un appareil de projection pour
les films dans la solution solution
changer une certaine façon de vivre dire
aux téléspectateurs qu'ils redeviennent
des spectateurs qui seront qui se
retrouvent dans leur salle de quartier
dans leurs salles de province qui
faisait la joie de rediscuter entre eux
le plaisir de discuter entre eux sur un
film
et puis aussi attendre de cela une autre
télévision et télévisions de fiction qui
elle aussi va les passionnés qui elle
aussi retrouvera ses vedettes entre
guillemets ses passions et ses
enthousiasmes
merci jean n'est pas terminée ce journal
donc le reportage de jacques séguin et
de jean-louis saporito à propos de route
racines se livrer ce feuilleton télévisé
donc diffusée sur antenne 2 en ce moment
et qui a conquis l'amérique il ya
quelques mois histoire étonnante d'un
universitaire noir américain alex haley
qui a voulu savoir comment lui noirs
américains étaient venus de son pays
d'origine l'afrique
il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années il a remonté la filière
jusqu'aux racines jusqu'aux sources le
correspondant aux états unis ont suivi
des noirs américains qui à l'instar de
l'auteur de route voulais retrouver
leurs origines leurs ancêtres étaient
partis d'afrique sur des bateaux de
négriers ils y reviennent eux à dakar en
charter
pendant une longue semaine route racing
avait captivé l'amérique
c'était en janvier 1977 et noir
américain prenait conscience de leur
origine
avec cette question éternelle qui
était-il d'où venaient-ils et c'est
pourquoi durant des semaines on a vu des
noirs américains s'entassant dans les
avions schachter prendre le chemin de
l'afrique pour y retrouver leurs
origines
moi
la première escale et dakar au sénégal
avant de remonter à la source
c'est-à-dire en gambie où l'écrivain
l'ex à l'est d'arras in situ l'histoire
de son ancêtre kunta kinte qui sera
déporté aux amériques par les négriers
et à dakar les descendants de culte akin
t aujourd'hui américain se retrouve face
aux africains entre eux première
différence
le dollar
au sauna
devant le palais du président senghor
que peut faire un américain sinon des
photos
léopold sédar senghor président du
sénégal
artes jour-là pour l'europe à l'aéroport
la compagnie à ces américains noirs
comme lui venu à la rencontre de la
négritude avec ce dialogue
jade ayela but non clé
vous êtes de quel état créé vous êtes de
quelle est ta foi new york
notre leur ligne ou ayo rapide ou be in
senegal in africa with love you i was
very impressed les images du feuilleton
racines ressemble de façon étonnante à
mon village dit senghor aujourd'hui
encore les américains y retrouvons la
même vie rurale et famille
non non non non du fuyard
pourquoi êtes vous venu ici vous savez
c'est à cause de cette fameuse histoire
de route de racines très populaire aux
états unis non nous n'avons pas trouvé
nos racines ici car aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous américains des américains
qui escaladent les tertres de la
chrétienté
ignorant sans aucun doute qu'ils de
l'occident chrétien du monde musulman
fut à l'origine de ce marchandage qui
transporta d'un continent à un autre
des milliers d'hommes appelés esclaves
les esclaves étaient réunis sur une
petite île au large de dakar le nom de
l'île gorée centre de pèlerinage et de
tourisme
voix
gori fut d'une possession française
explique liquide aux touristes et
américains qui écoutent presque avec
indifférence et c'est de cette petite
île que des milliers d'hommes loin aller
prendre le chemin des plantes à trois
américains en passant par ce qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui animée
et lille était le centre de transit le
plus important de l'ouest africain
dispose montrent l'effectif dans cette
maison ont varié entre 450 à saint cloud
hommes femmes jeunes
ok
celui-ci la martinoire on va ressentir
ses premières émotions
il s'attache co folklore 10 au pasteur
anglican ne parle jamais des
missionnaires démissionnaire qui au nom
de dieu ont colonisé l'afrique dans la
maison des esclaves visité par les
touristes américains restent un guide de
bonne volonté
monsieur n'diaye qui essaye de
reconstituer l'histoire vous aviez des
bateaux qui vous êtes radio net de
lampard et âmes et qui pouvait contenir
450 da c'est cesc là on les entasse et
et vous aviez des bateaux qui avaient
déplu des plafonds qui faisaient appel
de m dans les prix parce que les deux
bouts bienne avaler les europuces le
continent africain qu'il y avait déjà la
traite des noirs seulement au niveau des
tribus et la traite des noirs et c'est
justement est ainsi fier au niveau des
amériques qu'au moment de la découverte
de la culture la callas eu du côté du
tabac les arabes ils viennent en premier
- les arabes ont commencé depuis le 16e
siècle
j'ai reçu ici pas mal de diversité qui
m'ont dit c'est bien beau d'accuser un
petit peu les européens mais certaines
phrases telles qu à l'os et des tribus
parce que c'est un vendeur yaya mais
d'acquéreurs nos chefs de tribus étaient
vraiment complices je suis tout le temps
pas assez
quand je reçois les visiteurs noir ah
mais non seulement je me sens proche
d'eux mais je me dis pas qui parle de 20
est-ce que parmi ces noix âmes et kate
n'a pas qu'ils sont des ta famille par
exemple
tes cousins lointains des fois ça me
bouleverse
tu
et au moment du départ après deux mois
de séjour ici c'est paris c'est ça que
j'appelle justement la porte du voyage
sans retour à partir de ce portable pour
ses escales s'est alliée la fri
il restait à franchir la dernière étape
avec le voyage ajout fort et le village
de gambie bande de terre coincée entre
le sénégal où l'auteur de race in situ
l'histoire d'un africain compte à keynes
est capturé et envoyés dans les bateaux
jusque là c'est jour de fête aujourd'hui
et le compteur du village un griot et
les américains répondent nous sommes de
retour nous sommes de retour
nous sommes des vôtres enfin nous sommes
chez nous
alors réaliser la moulinette un truc
qu'on tente de nous faire l'écho ce
dîner flins yvelines tony hale câline
celle des aides aux petites villes et
aussi des api pour france 2 cette
commune sont visités en ce sens ont
plutôt boudé que l'amour et qu'elle a
condamné comme toute ville aux besoins
et à ses propres crédits d ivoire we'll
be back to see our canadien et
intervenants lumut a comme tony
et c'est seulement à l'occasion de ses
dernières scènes exubérante l'américain
noir de brooklyn et africains d'autres
jouent fort et auront eu le sentiment
fugitif d'appartenir au même racine
avec l'autre vous donne rendez-vous vers
23h35 pour le dernier journal d'antenne
2 je vous souhaite une très belle soirée